Sathya Narayanan: So moving on to the, kind of, the second part of it, the way we… and, like, you know, there is…
Sathya Narayanan: Yeah, so the… in the con… we are trying to do all of this in the context of…
Sathya Narayanan: AI, right? Like, how you use AI, what to…
Sathya Narayanan: people in the industry want from your ability to use AI, and this is something we have been thinking about a lot over the last
Sathya Narayanan: actually 2 years or so, but in the last 6 months, we've been talking and thinking about a lot.
Sathya Narayanan: the… the kind of the ideas that I want to plant in your mind, and we can talk more about it as we… as we go through the program, think about this idea of, like, a super agency plus human value. And what we mean by that is, we want to…
Sathya Narayanan: we should all try to use AI to be able to do more than what we could do before, right? Get a lot more work done, a lot more impactful work done.
Sathya Narayanan: But not in the sense that you are giving it to AI, and AI is doing the work, and then you are just submitting what AI gave, right? That's not the idea. Partner with it, don't outsource, right? And by not outsourcing is how you bring your human value into the equation.
Sathya Narayanan: So, keep these two words in mind, and again, we'll come back to it again and again, and try to define it more precisely for you.
Sathya Narayanan: But the idea of partnering with AI to be able to do more than what you can do by yourself.
Sathya Narayanan: But at the same time, making sure that you are contributing to it, right? And kind of another way of thinking about it is this notion of, I don't know if you… I heard this in a podcast, like a… I forgot who he said, I wish I had written it down, I was walking when I heard the phrase. This idea of, like, creating versus consuming, right? Like, are you…
Sathya Narayanan: when you're working with AI, are you able to see that you are contributing, you are also creating, you are also in creating mode, you are also contributing mode, rather than… are you just kind of having AI produce stuff that you are consuming? This is another way of thinking about this kind of super agency plus human value,
Sathya Narayanan: combination.
Sathya Narayanan: And so we have been thinking about this, and we built this tool we call, this, this, practice we call symbiotic thinking. Once again, you will… I will, I will…
Sathya Narayanan: Add, or one of us will add, more details about what symbiotic thinking means for you as you go through the process.
Sathya Narayanan: But I want to plant those seeds in your mind before we can jump into introducing an activity that we built for you, and I hope, you know, we hope this is going to be more interesting and kind of exciting for you.
Sathya Narayanan: So, kind of to summarize, keep in mind superagency plus human value. What you need to develop is super agency plus human value.
Sathya Narayanan: Being able to do more, super, like, kind of Superman, superwoman.
Sathya Narayanan: But also, you are bringing stuff to it, right? Your own value is coming in. And we are going to try to figure that balance out for each of us, and for each of us, it's different. So we need to kind of figure that out.